and by the way i also had a chance to
talk to dr ian about awards season and
he said kudos to hollywood for taking
pre-emptive steps in pushing all the
award shows back i mean they just want
everybody to be safe
trying to figure it out trying to do all
these things but there is controversy
because
the grammys have moved to march 14th and
that is the exact same day that the sag
awards has already picked
for their delayed show it's crazy
award starts right now
the pandemic is pitting the show where
actors award actors against music's
biggest night
if i were the sag awards i would be mad
too
quote we are extremely disappointed we
announced our date
last july they did have to move their
date because of the grammys
last year so it's it's two years in a
row there is beef
between these two award shows have you
had any conversations with sag-aftra
about the dates i've spoken to sag after
and look it's it's not a perfect
scenario for sure
uh we're both trying to deal with
navigating this global pandemic
there's no perfect weekend
and did the weekend just renew his beef
with the grammys
hours before news broke about the
rescheduled date the singer who was
snubbed in november released his music
video for
savior tears it shows him with a face
full of fake filler throwing a gold
trophy
off the stage the weeknd's an incredible
artist we'll always try and get these
things right but
it really comes down to the voters as
for this year's show on cbs
there will be live performances as
planned now
we're not planning on anybody attending
as far as an audience is concerned
tina where are the golden globes going
to be like under this new normal
that's a good question i have no idea
many wonder if the entire 2021 award
season could be in limbo
so far the oscars have been postponed to
april 25th
the globes february 28th i don't know if
we'll be together
well it's gonna be exciting to find out
you